beer or wine what do you prefer is the
big question okay Veranda at the Four
Seasons and Abel Baker Brewing Company
have partnered up to help you figure
that out their beer versus wine pairing
dinner is next Friday we have so Atlanta
coach and Chef William Ledesma to give
us a preview of The Experience first and
foremost beer or wine what do you guys
prefer what side are you on wine wine
wine
too okay the wine side is strong so
let's talk about what inspired this
collaboration so collaboration between
um Abel Baker and us we have a history
with them they did we did a couple of
events in the past and we're very
excited to continue that
incorporation with mental Vineyards this
is a new partnership with us so we're
really excited as well as them to do
this event together oh that's so cool
and I love that you guys are calling the
dinner or battle I should say a win-win
for everybody why is that what's the
experience like so experience will be it
will be five course tasting menu and it
will be have been banned for both wine
and beer lovers they will have
opportunity to taste and sample some of
the Brews local Brews from Abel Baker as
well as some of the wine pairings
together with the menu beautiful now
let's talk about the many perfect Segway
so I want to thank you Chef what is on
the menu for this dinner what are we
eating okay so it's a five five course
prefix menu and this this will be the
dish who opened the dinner so we have a
beautiful uh tuna and crab avocado
Tower so it's uh it's just a little bit
for everybody you know we have a little
Tuna we have a pear salad we have a
beautiful Ravioli and we will close the
dinner with amazing uh foie gras and New
York so like I said this is this is this
will be the the opening dish
uh something like Chris for for for uh
the first offerings oh I love it now so
Lana what are we wearing to this how how
fancy are we getting
experience everybody will be seated at a
communal table together uh having a
tasting together with the food as well
as they can discuss the beer which one
they prefer better wine you have experts
there talking to everybody so it's kind
of an educational experience too we will
have a chef film Desma in the center
talking about the food as they come as
well as our Tap Room Managers from Mabel
Baker and some milliers from living
there okay let's tell everybody how they
can get tickets or reservations Excuse
me while I go ahead and taste this if
you don't so this will be event for the
reservations only they can we can book
online on four seasons.com Las Vegas
so please make sure to join us for this
fun event and we'll get tickets in
advance thank you so much for Atlanta
Chef this is so good thank you JC I'll
send it to you this is